one time in this convention so typically
they don't put you on the first floor
like they're not supposed to yeah like
because
obviously that's where all the elevators
are yeah everyone's
all the people are there so yeah
typically they don't actually put guests
on the first floor they'll normally have
a floor
that's specifically for staff and guests
that's like separate so that
no attendee should be on the same floor
as a guest or a staff
that's what they're supposed to do but
sometimes the cons don't do that so
one of them i was on the first floor and
i was kind of annoyed because i was
literally
about 15 meters from the elevator
right so everyone everyone knows where i
come from a great place
yeah right next to it where do i come
from where do i go exactly
cotton niger so
it was just like asking someone to see
where i was staying and i'm sure most
people saw where i was luckily no one
took advantage of that but
at about like 2 a.m one night uh i'm
like
basically naked but i really wanted ice
and the ice thing was right next to
the
mission impossible right it's 10 seconds
in and out no problem
i'm in my boxes only right right i'm
just going to [ __ ] do it like i don't
care
who cares i open my i'm like building
myself up confidence i could have just
put a t-shirt on no
i'm building myself up i opened the door
and there's just two girls sitting there
opposite my door right and i'm like what
the [ __ ] i've been like [ __ ]
spongebob has been on like full volume
in my room dude like what are you
and you're naked and i'm like basically
naked and i'm like
go to the ice machine and i get it and i
go back in and i'm like as i'm closing
my door i'm like
what are you doing like nothing i'm like
all right then did they know you
i don't know i didn't ask i just closed
the door when they said nothing i'm like
all right i'm going back to bed
meanwhile they were like huge fans and
they're just creaming themselves maybe
maybe i mean they're basically watching
one of my cosplay videos so it's not
right i
saw sea dog va's nipples he came out
watching
for some reason he came out of his hotel
room butt naked watching spongebob i
don't want to ask why he was doing that
i just wanted ice no and one time i was
on like the seventh floor
in like minneapolis and i i went to my
room
no one else on this floor there was just
this like seven foot white dude just
sitting
in front of my door just sitting in
front of it literally blocking it and i
was like uh
hey can i get in my room he's like oh
yeah sure yeah i've had that plenty of
times too
like people random people sitting in
front of my door and it's almost always
people who don't know who i am yeah
because i'm like why are you here
because it's like a i mean at
conventions hotel rooms just become a
[ __ ] zoo yeah you know what i mean
i was just so confused i'm like okay
like he was literally like not even like
next to it like in front of my door yeah
yeah and i like kind of like i'm like
okay can you
move yeah i'm gonna get in my room like
why did why do these like attendees
think that like
hotel hallways are the same as
convention hallways right so you can't
just sit in the hallway
and i i didn't say anything because i
was like i'm gonna hope that when i
leave this room in 20 minutes after i've
had my shower yeah
you will not be there luckily he wasn't
yeah yeah yeah but i was like that was
just something
you've never had like the like the
getting a letter slipped under your
hotel door and stories people taking you
back to your room yeah
no they always like give it to my face
oh really yeah i had someone who uh
that's much nicer i wish i had that i
had someone who's like this is for you
and it was an envelope yeah i thought
yeah that's nice they've ridden me like
a little car
yeah yeah i noticed like this little
light yeah it's a little light yeah yeah
and the helper next to me is like oh you
should open it and i was i was like i
was going to leave it cause normally i
like leave until you get back because
people are still coming and i open it up
and it's a hotel key card and on the
envelope they've written their room
number
and i was like damn damn son
i just thought this is not the kind of
chris hanson trap i need to walk in yeah
i'm like this is no no no no no this is
like a james bond plot but no thank you
yeah
and like the the handler next to me was
like damn
it was like can i have that i was like
i like you i don't know it's nice